almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it let's talk
today about the concept of the lesser of
two evils are you evil if you choose the
lesser of two evils or should you
abstain altogether from being involved
in such a choice now of course the
context of all of this is that there are
people saying they're not going to vote
for Joe Biden instead of Donald Trump
because Joe Biden is merely the lesser
of two evils there are people who see
both Biden and Trump as evils although
maybe two different degrees and voting
for any evil would not be okay for them
so they might abstain or they might vote
third party or right someone in or
whatever the case may be another way
that some are saying it is those who are
focusing in on the sexual-assault
component of the current political race
there are people who write to me and say
David are you just saying I should
choose which sexual assault or I want
I either vote for a sexual assault or
with one allegation against them or a
sexual assault or with 26 that's not a
good choice for me I'm going to opt out
so let's really think this through and
take it in pieces there's this first
question of just arguing like is Biden
evil or is Biden not that good or like
what what what exactly is the
characterization of Biden in this
context I'm gonna argue that it doesn't
matter to me it's a distraction to say
is Biden good or simply less evil than
Donald Trump once you grant that Biden
is better than Trump if you don't then
vote for Trump then there's not even a
conversation if you think Trump's better
vote for Trump that's clear but once you
grant Biden is better than Trump I don't
think it matters whether Biden is less
evil or good for the purposes of the
conversation we're going to have today
secondly and this is really important
the concept of opting out because you
vote for evil there's no opting out here
folks if you're an American and you are
allowed to vote
there is no opting out you can choose
not to cast a ballot but from a left of
Trump perspective either way you're
participating you're influencing you
have a say a stake and and you are
you're affecting the outcome whether you
cast a ballot or not there are people
making themselves sort of feel okay
about not voting for Biden by simply
saying I'm opting out I don't like the
choices so I'm not going to participate
in a literal sense you aren't taking the
act of voting and going and doing it but
you're not opting out of the process if
you vote for Trump that's obviously a
vote against Biden if you don't vote at
all and believe Biden is less bad than
Trump but not good enough for you to
vote for him you're still helping Trump
with one vote it's a vote that Trump
does not need to overcome in order to be
re-elected so let's really cut through
the BS here Biden being evil or not
isn't relevant if we agree he's better
than Trump for our purposes today that's
all that matters
opting out and being a non actor in the
process as the rejection of both
candidates unless you renounce your
citizenship and aren't allowed to vote
you have a vote whether you use it or
not you are participating and your
actions are part of the ultimate
consequence so given all of that this is
actually quite simple if you were put in
a room with two buttons one button kills
ten people and one button kills a
million people and if you say I'm not
going to press a button someone else can
press the button for me is there any
question that you are acting in a way
that is improper is there any question
that you should obviously press the
button given that one of these two
buttons is going to be pressed that
saves nine hundred and ninety nine
thousand nine hundred ninety people
right nine nine nine nine nine zero
people of course you should press that
button that would be choosing between
the lesser of two evils killing ten
people is bad kill
1 million people is also bad and I would
argue it is worse but it actually again
doesn't matter whether you're choosing
between two evils because think about a
slightly different scenario than the one
I just gave you you're in the same room
there are also two buttons one button
kills a million people and the other
kills no one and resurrects one person
it brings back someone that died of a
car accident ok imagine that isn't the
right action obvious in both cases
resurrect one person versus killed 10
million killed 10 versus killed 10
million whatever the numbers are right
in either case these are the choices and
if you say leave it up to chance leave
it up to other people or I can take the
action that I know is the preferable
action of course I take the preferable
action any time now how do you justify
taking any action that could let other
people press the kill a million button
in either case I don't know how you
justify that this is why the debate
about is Biden sort of good but not that
good
vs. is Biden less bad than Trump it's
irrelevant
there is no responsible way to say I'm
gonna let other people choose and I
won't put in my vote for the less bad or
better option but if that was the full
analysis I would be doing a disservice
to this discussion there are
philosophical structures that would
defend not pressing any buttons so I've
sort of given you a more utilitarian
perspective but let's consider for a
second the philosophy of Immanuel Kant's
contain ISM German philosopher from
mostly the 18th century died in in the
first few years of the 19th century I
believe you could certainly take a look
at Con Thien ISM which is focused not on
end goals like I'm looking at the end
goal when I say if 10 or a million are
going to die let me do what I can to
make it 10 instead of a million kontin
ISM instead of focusing on the end goal
would deal more with one's duty and
acting in accordance with underlying
principles so if we focus on this lesser
of two evils idea
and we look at it in terms of the
principle one could have a content
aligned principle of I'm not going to
vote for bad people that I'm only going
to exercise my vote when I have someone
good to vote for because of a principle
I'm not going to do the utilitarian
focus on the end goal of killing fewer
people I'm going to justify not pressing
either button because it would violate a
principle of mine rather than focusing
on the harm reduction utilitarian
component but that's a fair argument
that that would be right out of content
ISM I believe that even in this case
even in this strict conte in defense of
the non vote to adhere to a principle I
think it still falls apart because in
the case of voting or not voting in the
United States both actions are a form of
participation once again whether you
vote or not you're participating either
way and what I mean by that is that the
act of voting in and of itself like the
cast filling out your ballot mailing it
in whatever it is in a moral sense
neutral right just filling out a piece
of paper you're either filling out the
piece of paper or you're not filling out
the piece of paper but once you
understand that either way you're
participating in deciding the outcome
you're no less of a participant by not
voting you are no more adhering to the
principle that you were trying to adhere
to in this content sense by not voting
whether you vote for Trump or merely
don't get in the way of Trump by not
voting you are still participating
because voting is a right that you have
as an American you are either way
participating in the outcome and thus
the non vote might make people feel like
they're opting out over principles and
having no impact choosing not to
participate but in reality you are just
as much of a participant whether you
vote or not and thus even a conte and
ethic of adhering to principles rather
than focusing on utilitarian and goals
fails to justify a non vote in this case
let me know where I'm going wrong I look
forward to the discussion